Speaker 1: adding to the very, very, very
bad ten day period of news for Republicans
and MAGA and former Trump officials,
Rudy Giuliani has now been notified.
He is indeed under criminal investigation in
that Georgia scam that they tried to pull.
New York Times reporting Giuliani is told he is a
target of Trump election investigation in Georgia.
Yeah. Lawyers for Giuliani have been told that
he's a target of a criminal investigation in
Georgia into election interference by Donald
Trump and his advisers, one of Giuliani's lawyers
said Monday. Giuliani spearheaded efforts to
keep Trump in power as his personal lawyer
and emerged in recent weeks as a central
figure in the inquiry conducted by Fanni
Willis, the DA of Fulton County, Georgia, which
encompasses most of Atlanta. Earlier this summer,
prosecutors questioned witnesses before a special
grand jury about Rudy's appearances before
state legislative panels in 2020. Remember,
that was when Rudy was flying around doing
these hearings. Nobody was under oath and Rudy was
farting at the hearings and transmitting COVID.
That's what they're referring to. He
spent hours peddling false conspiracy
theories about secret suitcases of democratic
ballots and corrupted voting machines. This is
the latest in a widening swath of trouble, writes
The Times. Though he got some good news, which is
that he's unlikely to face charges in the federal
criminal inquiry into his ties with Ukraine.
So we kind of have covered the Rudy story. Rudy
could have spent the rest of his days being
mayor, 911 and just kind of farting around, for
lack of a better term. But he chose this path.
He chose to hook his wagon to the horse that
is Trump. And now that path has consequences,
and it's Rudy's own doing. Will Trump say,
I barely knew the guy? Rudy really had no
role in anything. Is that what's coming? It
doesn't seem particularly likely. But what
we're learning is that being a lawyer for
Trump is a criminally risky thing to do.
Look at what happened to Michael Cohen.
Look at what happened to Sidney Powell,
who has now been disbarred in a number of
different places. Rudy's under a criminal
probe. Eric Hershman I believe Eric Hershman was
White House counsel. He now has been subpoenaed.
And we know years ago we started joking about how
MAGA really means making attorneys get attorneys.
It really seems to and couldn't have happened to
a nicer guy is what some are saying about Rudy
Giuliani. Maybe that's the case. Maybe he's a nice
guy. But these people do deserve it. These are
not victims. These are perpetrators. And I know
that because of the advanced age of some of these
folks, there is a reaction among some to say this
is sad, these are victims. At the end of the day,
just leave them alone. These are perpetrators.
And the victims are the United States and its
people. Those are the victims. And we'll see
where this goes. All of these clips you can find
on The David Pakman Show, Instagram, search,
Instagram for David Pakman show. Find us there